[Musique]
Tib et Jerry bonjour et je suis tout
seul mais j'ai envie de vous applaudir
bravo vous avez remporté le bcus d'or
c'était en janvier dernier
alors c'est lourd hein effectivement ça
fait 100 poid 5 kg comme ça c'est bon 5
kg 5
kg c'est magnifique comme concours enfin
de remporter ce concours quoi c'est un
concours on en parlait un petit peu
c'est c'est c'est quoi les Jeux
olympiques de de de la cuisine on peut
dire ça comme ça euh je pense qu'on peut
dire ça effectivement c'est un concours
qui est sans commun de mesure parce que
ça c'est un concours international on
est dans la finale on est 24 pays
sachant qu'il y en avait 60 pour les
sélections donc c'est un concours
exceptionnel qui a en plus le la
particularité de se dérouler face à à
2000 personnes dans une tribune doncours
voilà c'est à Lyon c'est c'est boucuse
he voilà dans le
fief comment vous avez décidé de de de
participer à ce concours comment ça
s'est passé en fait c'est un petit peu
le l'aboutissement de d'une longue
préparation en fait j'ai déjà fait pas
mal de concours dans la maison j'ai je
pense certaines aptitudes là-dedans et
c'est vrai que le le chef gekrenzer m'a
proposé un jour de me lancer sur le
bocus d'or donc donc les 15 premières
secondes j'ai cru à une blague et puis
ensuite ben non effectivement on est
parti dedans et vous avez cru une blague
au début bah c'est tellementus d'or
c'est c'est énorme et c'est c'est
vraiment l'occasion de réaliser un petit
peu son chef-dœuvre parce que c'est un
concours dans lequel vous vous faites
une affiche comme comme un livret pour
le jury comme fabriquer votre plat chez
leorfèvre de la porcelaine le livret est
absolument enfin en les plat étent
exceptionnel mais le livr est magnifique
aussi parce que il y a tous les dessins
qui vous ont inspiré qui qui ont qui ont
permis de de de réaliser les les plats
que vous avez fait alors il y avait deux
plats un produit une assiette et un plat
oua une assiette et un plat une assiette
de poisson alors c'était quoi ça c'était
nouveau donc en fait jusqu'à maintenant
on envoyé un plat de poisson comme pour
la viande là c'était la première édition
donc on avait imposé turbo eomar et
trois garnitures libres donc donc ben on
a réalisé un petit peu un turbo en de
Homar c'était assez osé en même temps on
était en plein dans le sujet on a essayé
d'apporter à l'assiette vraiment ce ce
raffinement pour rester dans le thème
versaill donc qui a le turbo donc qui a
une gelée très chic avec un motif or à
l'extérieur c'est c'était nouveau et ça
a beaucoup plu alors c'est vrai que vous
aviez pris le thème Versailles d'abord
c'est pas loin d'ici hein on est on est
chez chez vous l'école le NRE vous allez
enseigner he maintenant voilà c'est ça à
partir de maintenant ils ont dit ça y
est maintenant qu'il remporte les
concours faut quand même qu'il en fasse
profiter les c'est ça il y a un gros
savoir à transmettre là les nres
j'allais dire et donc on est oui on on
n'est pas loin de de de Versailles ici
enfin le siège de le nôre et puis c'est
vrai qu'il fallait quelque chose qui
symbolise évidemment tout de suite la
France c'est ça oui voilà en fait c'est
la première année où il y a 20 % de la
note qui est sur l'originalité
géographique c'est-à-dire que chaque
pays se devait de représenter sa culture
autant gastronomique que son
savoir-faire et donc on chercha un thème
fort identifiable par chacun des 24
juris donc on s'est dit Versailles ça
parlait à à pas mal de monde c'est vrai
que ça coïncide avec le tricentenaire du
jardinier de Versailles alors c'est ça
qui est formidable c'est que vous êtes
le nôtre et puis versaill c'est le NRE
en de mots mais de mot voilà c'est un
concours de circonstances en fait c'est
vrai que déjà à la base j'adore versaill
pareil j'habite à côté j'y suis
quasiment tous les weekends donc c'était
c'était vraiment un concours de
circonstances et ça ça tombait très bien
très très bien et qu'est-ce que alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez qu'est-ce qui
vous inspirer de du jardinier le nôre
pour pour le pour les pour les bah en
fait quand vous regardez les si vous
voulez le poisson et la viande les deux
sont dans cette idée de jardin de
versaill le plat de viande on est
vraiment très symétriques des
perspectives différents niveaux très ben
rigoureux comme peut l'être comme
peuvent l'être les jardins à la
française très ordonnés sur le plat de
poisson on est toujours floral mais bien
plus bien plus frais pas de pas de
symétrie pas de perspective c'est un peu
comme un mélange d'herbe du printemps
c'est ça ça sort comme ça et en fait on
avait vraiment les deux aspects du
jardin alors c'était turboom obligé pour
pour le poisson et et pour le pour le
plat c'est c'est un tourn d' Rossini ce
que vous avez fait en gros alors on
avait imposé en fait un filet de buuf
hierland plus au choix mais fortement
conseillé d'utiliser du paleron de bœuf
de la queue de bœuf et de la joue de
bœuf donc donc après ben le le choix de
la recette bœf dans l'idée d'un Rossini
c'est venu simplement c'est-à-dire que
il y a quelques mois on a mangé chez
Monsieur bocus à Lyon oui vous entez pas
quand même non mais ça fait partie de la
l'ation quoi ouisou et donc en fait il y
avait une salle comble forcément euh à
80 % d'étrangers et en fait quasiment
une assiette sur deux c'était un buff
Rossini dedans donc j'ai dit bon ben on
va pas chercher beaucoup plus loin c'est
que les étrangers ils aiment bien ça
sachant que l'idée du la difficulté du
concours international c'est qu'on
s'adresse plus à un jury
français un Brésilien comme un Japonais
donc il faut vraiment trouver ce goût
médian qui puisse plire à tout le monde
quoi sortir de nos c ça c'estàdire qu'
il faut à la fois il faut à la fois que
ça représente bah une société une
civilisation c'est un pays c'est la
c'est la France donc c'est vrai que tour
de Rossin on se dit bah il y a pas plus
classique quand même mais la façon dont
vous le réalisez et quand on voit les
les photos de ce que vous avez réalisé
il y a pas plus moderne que ça oui ou
c'est bah c'est exactement ce que ce
qu'on recherchait en fait c'était
quelque chose de très rassurant dans les
saveurs qui puisse plaire à tout le
monde parce que le but c'est de plaire à
tout le monde tout en travaillant des
techniques un visuel novateur et et
hyper moderne c'est sûr qu'on a on a
travaillé sur une brioche pleine avec
avec des motifs en relief ensuite bah on
a fait un montage avec notre bœuf donc
foie gras truff un petit peu de jus et
qu'on est venu inserrer dans la brioche
ça c'était du jamais vu et cé un sacré
Paris aussi parce que
euh c'est très risqué sur un concours il
y a S deibilit maisi vous étiz dit voà
je moi je vais faire le concours c'est
pas juste pour avoir une place d'honneur
pas juste pour y participer c'était pour
gagner hein ou c'est ça donc c'est voilà
tout pour le tout atre atteindre le
podium en fait c'est relativement simple
peut y arriver VO voilà mais après c'est
vrai qu'onétait dit celui qui veut
gagner faut qu' faut qu'il a un break et
qu'ène quelque chose d'é Nau et là c'est
vrai qu'on a fait c'était très risqué on
a pris un un comment dire un ensemble de
choix bah qui aurait pu nous mettre 20
fois dans le mur et on aurait pu se
rater bon après il y a aussi le côté
excitant du concours c'est une fois dans
sa vie donc tant qu' y aller on y va et
on gagne en beauté c'est quoi 5h3 de de
préparation voilà en fait vous démarrez
avec que des produits bruts et 5h 35
après vous devez avoir envoyé vos deux
plats chaud bien cuit assaisonné
d'accord nickel chrome donc c'est c'est
comment dire un timing très précis c'est
de l'horlogerie c'est vraiment c'est à
celui qui arrivera à imriquer le plus
les choses en timing les une dans les
autres pour en sortir le maximum en 5h35
on pas le temps de se rouler les pouces
quoi ah non non non non sur les images
je pense que ça se voit pendant 5h35 on
touche pas le sol comment ça se passe
d'ailleurs alors la veille vous faites
les courses alors ça c'est une nouveauté
de cette iition c'est que sur l'assiette
de poisson en fait sur les trois
garnitures on est obligé de faire trois
garnitures et il y en a deux qu'on a dû
composer avec un marché de saison qu'on
a découvert la veille donc voilà donc
c'est ça amène beaucoup de spontanéité
dans le concours ça vient casser
justement ce côté
répétitif d'entraînement là on fait plus
de la place pour la cuisine spontanée la
cuisine de saison aussi c'est vrai que
c'est super important de ramener ça dans
un concours et et donc il a fallu
composer deux garnitures la veille et
les réaliser le lendemain donc ça c'est
une grande première et ça s'avère être
enfin je trouvais que l'idée était
géniale moi vraiment ça ça fait du bien
de ramener ce
côté
spontané un concours justement ouis
parce que c'est complètement inattendu
alors voilà il y a cette réalisation les
5h3 on fait le plat on se dit vous êtes
dit à un moment ouais c'est bon là je
vais gagner ou on est on est tendu on
est dans son truc et parce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'entre l'entrée dans le
box jusqu'à l'annonce de la première
place nous en backstage on a eu
absolument aucun écho on a vu passer
aucun plat aucune caméra personne qui
est venu nous dire c'était extra ce que
vous avez fait donc jusqu'à l'annonce de
la première place on était complètement
vous pouvez passer à côté des fois ça
arrive aussi bon on savait qu'on avait
envoyé quasiment à 95 % ce qu'on avait
prév donc ça c'est déjà une première
victoire en soi après il y a toujours
plus fort que soi he bon bah là c'est
nous qui avons on a cartonné c'était
c'était bien alors ça c'est bon c'est un
peu le final tout ça les courses la
préparation oua mais alors ça se prépare
combien de temps à l'avance un concours
comme ça alors ça se prépare on a le
sujet pour la viande du moins on l'a eu
1 an à l'avance mais mais ça vous
empêche pas moi il y a déjà 18 mois je
réfléchissais déjà au thème vous avez
pas le comment dire le sujet imposé mais
ça vous empêche pas de réfléchir déjà au
volume aux formes et après vous intégrez
le thème dedans et puis après il y a une
grosse phase en fait de de réflexion
forcément au final on touche le produit
vraiment que à la fin parce que il y a
beaucoup de de modélisme de peinture de
croquis de comment dire de 3D en factice
en maquette mais pour se rendre compte
de l'harmonie des des formes ensuite
vous passez sur l'harmonie des couleurs
et puis ensuite vous y intégrez la
notion de goût et pour que Ben le tout
soit harmonieux et soit bon he c'est le
but c'est la base et puis ensuite
seulement vous passez dans la phase de
répétitivité enfin de répétition où vous
enchaînez les concours g Tech pour pour
gagner en précision et en régularité
alors alors il y a un côté créatif un
côté très esthétique chez vous vous êtes
photographe aussi c'est votre deuxième
métier on peut dire est-ce que ça ça ça
ça aide ça parce que vous avez l'œil non
ah c'est j'en suis persuadé moi c'est et
c'est même des fois déroutant parce que
en fait vous commencez à à faire une
grosse esquisse vous la montrez à vos
collègues qui perçoivent pas forcément
ce que vous vous avez dans votre cerveau
en fait en voyant une maquette je vois
déjà le plat fini donc c'est là où c'est
difficile en
fait et en fait ça peut être vraiment
sommaire la maquette et vous vous êtes
sûr sûr et certain que ça va le faire
alors que vos collègues des fois sont
pas donc ce regard de photographe c'est
certain que dans l'approche du de
l'assiette de la vision de l'assiette et
comme je disais en fait c'est que la
cuisine aujourd'hui elle doit être
exceptionnellement bonne mais plus que
jamais elle doit être aussi belle ça
c'estelle c'est nouveau donc avec voilà
ou alors qu'avant avant on avait des
présentations peut-être un peu plus
brouillant enfin Mo travaillé
aujourd'hui cette notion de design dans
l'assiette elle est vraiment primordiale
alors vous avez vous êtes chez bokus
chez bcus chez le nôre chez bocus aussi
ENF vous êtes chez lere depuis quand
c'est ça va faire 6 ans que je suis ici
ouais 6 ans et avant vous avez é chez
tavon chez George blanc voilà c'est ça
en fait après avant le NRE j'ai un
parcours de gastro cuisinier gastro
classique c'est-à-dire qu'en fait j'ai
fais l'école hôtelière ensuite j'ai
attaqué chez George blanc Michel Guérard
Michel kezer ensuite je suis resté c'est
quand même des belles formations B j'ai
toujours pour principe qu' peut le plus
peut le moins donc j'ai tapé directement
dans ce qu' avait de plus dur et puis
après ça vous paraît plus simple donc et
puis au Taïwan où j'ai fait 5 ans j'ai
fait de la cuisine tout ce qu'il y avait
en cuisine tout ce qu'il y avait en
pâtisserie et puis ensuite j'ai eu
l'occasion de rentrer chez le NRE c'est
des formations exigeantes aussi hein
c'est exigeant c'est des Ty comme blanc
comme gara c'est des c'est des c'est des
gens formidables mais c'est c'est des
gens très exigeants aussi hein B dans ce
métier de toute façon comme on dit hein
c'est facile de faire bon une fois mais
le propre d'un grand restaurant c'est de
faire bon midi et soir et toujours la
même chose donc là c'est sûr que ça ça
nécessite une une rigueur et une une
régular ité ben que seul ces grandes
maisons ont donc c'est sûr que vous vous
faites quelques heures vous rentrez vous
êtes rincé mais c'est hyper enrichissant
le le le le prix bcus évidemment ça vous
amener beaucoup de propositions je
suppose non de gens qui vont vous dire
faut ouvrir votre votre
restaurant on s'attend pas bon quand
vous êtes dans le concours vous avez
autre chose à penser que l' près bus
faut déjà gagner mais c'est vrai que
c'est passer de l'ombre à la lumière
instantanément c'est assez
perturbant ou très heureux et comme
comme je dis souvent en fait j'ai
toujours fait les concours pour
apprendre je cherche pas la lumière en
fait et c'est vrai que dans la maison il
y a un savoir-faire qui est unique que
ce soit en boulangerie en glace on a une
palette de compétences qui qui est
unique au monde on a un champion du
monde de somellerie on a vous avez oui 7
ou h ou mil de France
Heou dans Fabrice Prochasson qui était
votre coach pour le pour le concours
donc oui c'est entre autres donc donc là
vous voilà c'est un lieu d'excellence
quoi bah pour celui qui a envie
d'apprendre c'est le paradis demande si
un jour on arrivera à faire le tour
tellement qu'il y a de savoir làdedans
mais maintenant le paradis c'est vous
puisque vous allez avoir des élèves qui
vont apprendre avec merci merci
beaucoupb
[Musique]
bravo